in the lobby of Ramsey solutions David
and Emily are with us hey guys how are
you good thank you an awesome welcome
it's so good to have you so where are
you from
San Antonio Texas and all the way to
Nashville to do a debt free scream yes
sir how much have you paid off about two
hundred and fifty thousand Wow how long
did that take just about four years four
years excellent and range of income
during that four years started out about
120 and about 230 now Wow what are you
going to do for a living I'm a physical
therapist I'm a high school teacher and
coach wow you guys are kicking it way to
go well done so is that your house and
everything I wish no that was that we
had what was it so about a hundred and
twenty thousand student loans credit
debt cars personal debts a new IRS
audits two babies were born a house fire
I mean there was wow we have to at cash
flow maternity leave because that was on
paid for as well so you were normal
we've had every possible debt out there
yes you were huge you were in deep you
were in a mess yes sir that time making
120 yeah in the house fire huh yes sir
that really turned our lives upside down
and put a pause on everything and she
was also pregnant at the time with our
little one oh it was brutal
Wow so it was the house fire four years
ago New Year's 2012 so about four years
yes sir right it so what so you're going
through that crisis is that what made
you stop and say all right this is out
of control we got to change things is
that what did or what flipped the switch
what started this actually going to your
conference kind of flip the switch for
us uh home that was one wake-up call and
then when we got married we actually sat
down and put all our bills all our ducks
together and it was just mind-blowing we
did not realize how much money we owe to
we actually sat down and did the numbers
okay and then you're tearing into it and
then the house burned yes yeah Wow
just about the time you get started the
whole world falls apart he had like I
said she was on board she'd listen to
your show and she kept trying to get me
on board and we said let's come with me
to the Money Makeover conference in San
Antonio and I said
let's go you know whatever from that
moment on you had me hooked and then I
became the financial accountant and on
the money now I'm here doing the class
Wow very cool so you let your leading FP
you we teach effort well we have yet to
or just now leadership so I'm in the
master coach training as well okay so
very cool way to go guys
absolutely incredible very well done
that's a lot of money yeah what was the
what was the hardest part of this for
years to get two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars paid off probably
watching all our friends go out to eat
seeing everybody go on vacation and we
had to say no and had a lot of movie
nights a lot of chicken quarters chicken
quarters yes so many of our friends and
people and family and everybody is going
out doing things and I had to cancel and
say no and we didn't get to do a lot of
things that we wanted to do but yeah
sacrifice was well worth it we were able
to sell our house and pay off all our
debt at the last of it and get ourselves
our three to six months emergency fund
and we built our dream home just
recently moved in in November Wow very
cool it's really been crazy that's nice
icing on the cake after but having one
burn yes yeah yes that's oh that's a
nice end of the story right there that
this portion of the story anyway
yeah very cool very cool so what do you
tell people the key now you've been
through the master coaching series this
week and you've lived for years of beans
and rice rice and beans and chicken
quarters and to get out of debt what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of debt is you want to go ahead just
working together we have to both be on
board or it's not gonna work there was a
lot of a lot of moments where he almost
fell off and I almost fell off and we
respect each other and kept us focused
that's the main thing and then my
favorite part was our whiteboard but a
giant whiteboard in the living room and
every time people come over they look at
our whiteboard it was all our bills
biggest to smallest and our was a slave
as borrowed to the borrower slave to the
lender was our quote on the whiteboard
and what I was able to do was map out if
we paid this much money we were paid off
by this day if we could find an extra
$100 fine
hundred dollars were paid off by this
day and that was so motivating I mean we
cut off months and months and months by
looking at that whiteboard every day Wow
well just keep that goal right in front
of you every day hit real clear in front
of you that visualization helps you yes
the fact that you can see the numbers
right there and you're going yeah you're
going down
yes yeah I love it very very inspiring
very cool when you got sat down after
going to the event you had to be
thinking $250,000 this is gonna be so
hard
what part of this was easier than you
thought it was going to be when you
first started easier hmm
I can tell you what there was not a
whole lot that was easy it was hard it
was very difficult but I'll tell you
what she I have to give to people all
the credit
well three I guess god of course you're
very humbled Dave you don't take a lot
of credit but your guidance really
helped us but she kicked it in overdrive
she really saw tons and tons of patience
and I mean she was working like a dog
like we used to say and I'll tell you
what she was getting after it and I made
him lunch every day for work so he
couldn't eat out and then you went or
Wow very very cool well how does it feel
now amazing it's we still haven't really
experienced yet we're still living we're
so used to budgeting and not being able
to enjoy it and now we're just kind of
like teeter tattering around should we
do this should we do that and it's been
a weird adjustment but I'll tell you
what it feels absolutely free I mean
it's amazing
mm-hm it's a good word good word and you
got three kids with you yes yeah I came
on the trip and the ages are what nay in
name's Omar he's 17 mm-hmm Sadie's she's
4 and we have little Aubree she's 200 so
there's the four year oh wow from the
day from from the time that started then
yes and then Sadie came home since then
okay very cool all right David and Emily
Omar Sadie in Aubrey two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars paid off in four
years making 120 up to 230
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream three two one we're dead well
well done well done I love it absolutely
love it very very well done hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show and so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind